but here it is
[Music]
oh
before we get to going on this video
here's me hello
i have a question have you ever bought
something online to then realize you
could have gotten it for less that is
literally worse than accidentally
killing your dog in minecraft okay not
really but
luckily i discovered honey
honey is a free browser extension that
lets you save money online the way honey
works is that it scans the internet for
coupon codes whenever you check out and
just like unicorn wizard magic it puts
it out and saves you money amazing honey
literally knows about every single
coupon code there is you know those
weirdos at the mall with all those
coupon codes that's honey imagine having
an army of those working for you for
free
that's honey honey knows about over 20
000 websites such as amazon alibaba
gamestop you're a gamer razer works on
razer when you buy your pewdiepie
headphones honey will save you money and
you don't have to do anything extra
honey will do all the work for you when
you check out and i gotta say it feels
amazing it feels almost as good as
hitting 100 million subscribers
the feeling is actually completely
mutual
i usually use honey for amazon because i
buy a lot of dumb stuff for my videos or
stuff for my home
and it's just nice to save extra money
because then i have more money to buy
more dumb stuff that i don't need
i think it's just a good feeling knowing
you're paying the absolute lowest price
you can for something honey is for
everyone and it works for anything you
buy online go join honey.com
pewdiepie i know other youtubers have
promoted honey but if you haven't
downloaded honey now now is the time to
do it it's free it doesn't cost anything
and it saves you money now why am i
getting angry about it i am literally
getting angry about it because it's so
easy it's such a win-win service you
literally can't lose anything from using
it it takes two clicks to install
link is in the description do it it says
mr b says unless you hate money you
should download honey join honey.com
also big thanks to honey for helping me
celebrate this huge milestone of 100
million let's get in with the video
nine years ago i uploaded my first video
onto youtube
this is what that video looked like
it blew up i got millions of views and i
was big right away
no instead of 12 million views this
video had about three or four
this is what my content actually looked
like back in that day
and i am back with black ops with an
awesome game of search and destroy it
wasn't good
it wasn't engaging
it wasn't even original but
i loved it
it took so many uploads just for me to
hit even 100 subscribers and hitting a
hundred subscribers was huge
huge for me
and yeah today we're gonna celebrate
because i got 100 subscribers oh my loud
100 subscribers
it's funny looking back to that video
and what i said
i obviously had big goals
i like to aim even at big goals even
though they might not be relevant at all
but uh no no i don't wanna i don't wanna
be famous but at that time i was 20
years old i was living in sweden in a
small flight i had just moved away from
home i had no idea what i was doing i
just knew i enjoyed it
i was also studying at university at the
time industrial economics and management
my calling in life that's what i want to
do so i decided this youtube hobby
i'll probably have to set aside because
i should probably focus on my finals so
i upload a video saying i was going on a
break but in reality
i was i was quitting this was it for me
just can't put
my hobby in front of
that right now so uh i'm sure a lot of
you i'm sure most of you will understand
that and
i'm gonna miss you guys a lot actually
which was a pretty reasonable choice to
make considering i had about five people
that actually watched me during this
time
but luckily the break didn't last long
just a few days later i was back
uploading videos again
i had found what i was actually
passionate about and i wasn't ready to
just let it go i knew that a career in
youtube was
so far away
it was more of a myth than a dream at
this point because people didn't even
know if it was possible but it was
always at the back of my mind that there
was a tiny chance that this could
actually happen i was back uploading
videos and i tried out this new horror
game that had just come out called
amnesia and it was scarier than anything
that
it didn't even compare
welcome back
and the top comment of this video really
says it it is what started it all for me
at least
i wasn't popular as soon as i played
amnesia but for the first time the five
people that watched my videos
they really enjoyed it and i could tell
i was on to something and this wasn't
just new for me it was a new thing on
youtube as well and i had never played
horror games before it was genuinely
horrible
i made montages and compilations of the
best moments where it's really just me
screaming
they're kind of loud they're kind of
obnoxious but
they got a charm to them
[Music]
eventually i had grown a thousand
subscribers but it was also clear i had
grown an audience that really cared
about me i used to be an introvert and
but youtube really helped me open up
because on the other side there was
people that really appreciated the side
of me that i didn't show to anyone
at this point i had completely failed
school
i'm sorry mom and dad
my passion was somewhere else and i
famously started selling hot dogs to
sustain myself but i look back at this
time with great memories because i was
finally pursuing my goal my dream
not selling hot dogs but making videos
in my spare time that is
at this time i managed to meet a girl
online
who later became my wife
i won't bore you with every step of the
way of the journey
it it's been long
it had its ups and downs
i made a lot of mistakes on the way but
i've grown
i feel like i have at least and i feel
like i've finally come in terms with the
responsibility i have as a creator
about 100 million subs too late but you
know
but the channel's done a lot of good too
a lot of things i'm truly proud of we
literally raise millions of dollars to
charities and i'm really proud of my
audience for helping me do that
looking back at myself in that flight in
sweden is a very surreal experience i
would never
ever have imagined this outcome beyond
my wildest dreams came true ten times
over a hundred times over
i'm nine years older now
i'm still awkward as [ __ ] but i finally
got confidence in myself
and i'm really proud of who i am today
and instead of 100 subs
we hit a hundred million subs
we did it
i want to thank all the people i work
with over the past couple years you know
who you are i want to thank the people i
collaborated with
i want to thank all the great friends i
met along the way i want to thank my
previous and current editors michael
bride cybe i want to thank my family for
supporting me in doing something that i
didn't even know what it was
and i want to thank marzia for being by
my side every step of the way
but most importantly
i want to thank the pros
i don't need to tell you about the
journey
you already know it
profess
got a letter in the post
hmm what is this
i like the color scheme youtube
very nice it even got a letter from
susan
i won't read the whole thing but it
finishes with congratulations again on
becoming marcia's husband and please
give sven a big hug from us
thank you susan
now if you've been on twitter you've
seen this already
but here it is
let me get this out of the way oh my god
i've smudged it already
pewdiepie congratulations on passing 100
million subscribers and a lot of people
wanted a custom
reward but
i don't care this is awesome and of
course thank you youtube
where would i be without you
that's it for me for now please
subscribe we're trying to hit a thousand
million is that a billion oh my god
let's get it
we have to beat i'm just kidding
see you gamers tomorrow
you